Hey, David, are trumpet's really going to boycott
the Georgia Senate elections? Don't they realize
they'll just lose if they do it? Yeah, this
is a great question. Earlier in the week,
we talked about how by insisting that the
Georgia election was rigged on November 3rd
and that even though Donald Trump really won, this
is the claim from some on the right, even though
Trump really won, Joe Biden was given the election
and the electoral votes in Georgia because of some
theft or wrongdoing or subterfuge. We talked about
how by saying that you're at least implying that
the same would take place on January 5th when we
have these two Senate runoff elections, which will
actually decide control of the Senate. Raphael
Warnock, Democratic challenger against incumbent
Kelly Lefler, John USCIRF, Democratic
challenger to incumbent David Perdue.
When you insist it's rigged, it's rigged. It's
rigged. If people believe that, they might say,
why the hell am I going to vote? If it's
rigged, if my vote isn't going to count,
if the Democrats are going to steal it anyway, I'm
going to stay home. And so over the last few days
and at her debate against Raphael Warnock,
you saw Kelly Lefler talking about this.
They are now going to everybody must vote.
And it's sort of incoherent. It's sort of,
I guess. The case they're making is
it's rigged, but if we vote enough,
we might be able to overwhelm the rigging. The
reality is that it's Republicans in Georgia
that have actually rigged the elections.
If anybody has through voter suppression
tactics that have been completely out in the open
voter purges, removing people from voter rolls,
reducing early voting hours, so on and so forth,
we've been covering it for a very long time.
Do I think ultimately that many Republicans are
going to stay home because of the conspiracy
theories? I don't think so. I don't think so.
And before, you know, this is actually become
a little controversy within the show's audience on
the Monday show, I said I have been advocating for
more participation and more voting for a decade
on this program. So I'm not going to suggest to
Republicans that they not vote because it goes
against one of the fundamental principles that
I have. Obviously, I would rather Republicans
see the light and vote for the right people,
but I wouldn't be able to live with myself if now
I start saying stay home, Republicans. But I did
say I'm not going to go out of my way to change
Republican minds if they've already been convinced
not to vote by claims that it's rigged. And I
actually got a few emails from people saying,